Олексій Гончаренко європейська
Солідарність важливий закон бо він дає
можливість запрацювати дійсно вищій раді
правосуддя і провести конкурс на нових
дисциплінарних інспекторів нас 2,5 роки
не працювала Вища рада правосуддя має
працювати але на жаль друзі В нас є інші
органи які абсолютно не діють в тому
числі такий ключовий орган як Кабінет
Міністрів України по-перше Я хочу
спитати Чому нема годин запитань до
уряду чому на тій декілька днів коли ми
засідаємо тут не може бути присутній
урядовці і відповідати на наші питання
але саме головне йогонебне що відбулося
зараз Справа в тому що ми з вами
прийняли закон в якому я маю честь буде
співав автором І багато хто з вас є там
моїми слів авторами про відпустки для
військових предоплати військовим Згідно
цього закону до 30 липня кабінет
міністрів був зобов'язаний внести зміни
в свій порядок свою постанову про
порядок виплати грошового забезпечення і
бойових доплат військовослужбовцям до 30
липня і просто це не зробив Не виконав
закон не виконав свою роботу і зараз
десятки тисяч українців які воюють за
нашу державу всі нацгвардійці всі
прикордонники не отримали в липні жодної
копійки бойових доплат жодної ті хто
віддає сьогодні своє життя за країну не
отримали доплати Сьогодні в нас 8 серпня
вони в липні вже не отримали і до сих
пір Кабмін не може це розглянути вчора
на кабміні вони розглядали про новий
технічний регламент
еко-дизайну побутових пральних машин от
на це в них час є на українських
військових часто немає це ганьба це не
негайно має бути припинено